this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsay show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we talk about your
relationships
your money your work and your life it is
a free call at triple eight eight two
five five two two five some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it triple eight eight two five five
aaron is starting us off in salt lake
city utah hi erin welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave and john it's a pleasure to
speak with you today you too what's
up so my wife and i are getting really
close to getting out of our student loan
debt and we're really looking forward to
living the debt free lifestyle cool and
we're just curious we still have a
couple credit cards open and we just
want to know like how that works in
closing those down and what how long is
the process
it takes to basically get rid of your
credit history and credit score
well your history will stay with you
seven years from the date of last
activity on each item 10 years if the
item was a chapter 7 bankruptcy so if
you close that credit card account that
account will show up for seven years but
it'll get obviously progressively older
and when someone looked at your credit
bureau report they could tell hey they
closed they closed that credit card five
years ago and so it really doesn't start
to count in any way for you against you
or anything after a couple of years but
it still shows up now that's that's the
show up part
if you shut down every single account
you have no outstanding
credit
account of any kind
and they're all closed and zero balanced
about six months later you will have no
credit score
might be nine months might be nine
months might be 12 but somewhere in that
six to 12 months
okay so in in when we're looking to move
or eventually buy a home
those things won't show up in say a
couple years and we can do the whole
underwriting process that you talk about
they will show up but you won't have a
credit score and you would do a manual
underwriting with a zero credit score an
undeterminable credit score
so i mean
so for instance i filed chapter 7
bankruptcy when i was 28 years old i was
38 years old and it was still on there
but it didn't count against me
anymore because it was 10 years old you
know at that point and i wasn't
borrowing money anyway so it didn't
matter but and it doesn't it did not go
towards creating a credit score there's
no activity so the first thing i did was
make sure everything was shut down and
closed and zeroed
and there was no continued activity
because if you have an outstanding bad
debt that stays on there because they're
gonna they're gonna keep active keep
adding activity to it where they're
trying to collect what you owe so bad
debt being on there will keep open your
credit score and keep it low
uh but you'll if you have zero accounts
of any kind
showing up on your credit bureau report
as active
they're all closed and they're all zero
balanced then uh it doesn't take that
long for your credit score to evaporate
which is wonderful i i've had some
instances over the last few years where
just buying
maybe buying insurance or buying a
cell phone
a lot of different companies are asking
hey we want to run we just want you to
know we're going to have to run a credit
report on you and it's
and i tell them i'm paying with cash the
gab is just part of the thing and it
seems like more and more that score they
want to know who they're dealing with
well they're trying to
figure out if they can sell you
something is part of what they're doing
in some cases now with insurance there's
insurance gets rated if you don't have a
credit score okay you're going to get a
little more expensive right okay because
there's a bogus study uh that was done
probably 25 years ago the university of
texas the university of pennsylvania did
it together
that showed that people with low credit
scores had a
paid uh had higher claims
on their car insurance and their
homeowner's insurance were more likely
to have a higher claim on their a claim
at all and a higher claim uh what they
didn't the reason i call it bogus is
which does make sense because these are
broke people as i say that's that's but
that's bad that's the best statistical
fishing there well the but the thing
they left out the reason i call it bogus
is they left out the person with a zero
credit score right
which you would find someone like me
almost never files a claim right because
i've got tons of money in the cash and i
just pay cash and just fix the car or
whatever it is i mean so so it it uh you
know if they had done the study a little
bit more thoroughly someone like but i
pay a higher
car insurance rate because i have a zero
credit score huh that's fascinating and
uh you know so that that's but that's
yeah that's and it's just because it's a
bad
you know the entire industry used it as
an excuse to raise rates
so it was a bad study why would somebody
in your net worth situation still carry
car insurance well you carry liability
because you have to yeah that's right
legally well and it's inexpensive the
liability portion is i actually carry
full yeah coverage anyway because i
drive expensive cars and it just i just
take care you know and i've got what's
called stated value we're not going to
negotiate about the value of the car if
it's gone it's just gone and you just
write me that check gotcha and that's a
little more expensive too so it's a high
but a super high deductible
carry a huge deductible but an expensive
vehicle you know you're driving a
hundred thousand dollar raptor yeah you
know or eighty thousand nine that's not
a raptor then that's you know
in that situation you're probably gonna
make sense i still do i still do carry
those but there's it's a at that point
it becomes the decision i'm going to pay
this money for the yeah for the the sole
tax right yep yep so we're thinking
about it just taken care of yeah i think
about it i like that um but the uh
and the deductible the high deductible
makes the price reasonable yep so run
the deductible way up
uh but anyway the so the
but on the cell phone uh that's
completely bogus yeah uh they'll sell
your cell phone with that oh absolutely
yeah yeah and uh and what i do in those
kinds of situations because my cell
phones are through our company we've got
a bazillion cell phones so it's a
different it's a corporate contract but
if i were walking in and some situation
pops up like that with me today or with
you today i just go uh not only do i
have a zero credit score but my credit
bureau reports frozen yeah and so you
can't access it so good luck with that
yeah it's not gonna it's not gonna work
out you want my business right not gonna
work out do you want this money or not
you know and they're like okay yeah
we'll take your money that's right okay
and we'll figure it out yeah yeah and uh
but there's very i mean i've not had
any services of any kind that i've
wanted denied
in
20 years yeah i've never had anything
denied but in the first 10 years when i
i mean when i started this stuff with no
credit cards i was walking around with
no credit card they didn't have debit
cards
so you had to have so
i'm like yeah and i did run into places
that you know i couldn't get in a hotel
without a credit card you know i
couldn't run a car with a cash and there
was no debit card as a substitute that
was just as good you know so i didn't
have that as an option and uh of course
in those days online didn't exist right
the internet had done exist in that in
that decade
so uh but that you know it was
interesting i
went to speak one time on people getting
out of debt and uh they had reserved the
company i was speaking for had reserved
me a rental car when i got off the
airplane they wouldn't let me have it i
had to call a cab
wow
that's sticking to your principles
though man it's
yeah i was not not having another credit
card i'm done with them forever that was
30 plus years ago this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money thank you for joining us
america we're glad you're here matthew's
in knoxville hey matthew how are you
hey dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so my question is my wife and i we've
been married three years uh so far we've
had a baby boy named parker and we have
done everything to a tee for your
standards we got married we paid off 40
000 in her school loan we cash flowed
her grad school she's a nurse
practitioner now graduated in may we
just now bought a house and stayed a
down payment for it and now we're just
struggling
to know for saving enough money per
month way to go man congratulations do
you have your emergency funding done at
three to six months yeah we have a ten
thousand dollar emergency fund what's
your household income
so right now i want to part-time so i
can stay home and babysit our little kid
so right now our household income is
between 130 and 140 without my wife's
bonus checks of 20 000 each year
okay
and are you and are you saving 15
of your household income into baby step
four into retirement
yes so we put a thousand dollars every
month into our roth iras and after that
we're only saving around 1500 after
everything's paid for and which is
unusual for us because we just now
started our roth before that we're cash
flowing school and saving up for a down
payment so we got used to saving three
four thousand dollars a month and now
are you familiar with our baby steps
process
yes okay baby step four is saving 15
percent
you're out of debt okay so your other
type of saving and you have your
emergency fund your other types of
savings are are done we're working the
baby steps here so baby step four is 15
of your income
going into retirement and so that would
be
22 thousand dollars or so twenty
something thousand dollars a year
okay somewhere going into retirement
does she have 401k available at her
place
yeah yeah we i think we put in five to
ten percent here at the hospital okay
well you need to add up
your total income times 15
and make sure you're putting that amount
away in total
and no more okay
into retirement
no more than that everything above that
would go to parker's college fund baby
step five and baby step six above that
we're gonna start paying down the house
quickly
and so what you where you would have
been throwing money additional monies
into savings now you're putting a little
of it into parker's get him a fund
started and for college and then beyond
that we're going to get this house
knocked out
okay that makes sense it is really hard
for us because like i said we've been so
disciplined and saving like three four
thousand months down to like 1500 a
month after everything's paid for 1500 a
month is not enough yeah
right right so that that's that's the
point and hey matthew let me give you
one little piece of advice from this
point forward never say you're
babysitting your own kid it's called
parenting
okay
so you're gonna you're gonna save
yourself some heartache with your wife
and other people just say hey i'm gonna
stay at home go part time to parent my
kid not babysitting you babysitter's a
teenager that you hire off from
an app or something i don't know off a
local school or something there you go
there's my two cents on that call dave
that works kathleen's in cincinnati hi
kathleen how are you
i'm doing great i'm very blessed thank
you so much good how can we help
okay um
chris was coming home we had
doing great and my husband decided to
hit the pavement on the side of the
highway so
now we have an issue where we have to
retire we're both 64. right i don't know
your husband
i don't understand your husband hit the
pavement what are you saying yes his
heart
did he pass away
no no no he's he's still alive it's just
that he asked me to pull over i pulled
over he acted like he was going to get
sick and next thing i know he splat on
the ground
and here we found out it was his heart
oh he had a heart attack
well they say it was afib
so anyway all i know is he's got a
pacemaker now okay we get home doctor
says he has to retire we weren't
planning on retiring
him retiring until he was 66 and
two-thirds
but he's going to have to do it this
year
stop stop slow down
okay but he's doing okay now
yeah for right now what does he what
does he do for a living
he's an engineer
okay
and that affects your heart
he is in a stressful situation
oh so the stress of the
in the work of the work environment
yes
okay and the doc says that's
contributing to his
heart issues
right
i would recommend meeting with another
doctor yeah not that that he may need to
leave that job
um
but the idea that the solution to stress
is to do nothing
well it's not actually for him to do
nothing just to leave that company
because he's okay being the engineer
mentality he's not one to just sit at
home
right
leaving that company is different than
just not working anymore
yeah but he would like to have that
choice which i understand where he's
coming from
okay the question they really have is
we're totally out of debt except for the
house
i owe 68 000 on the house
we have been pretty much living on half
his paycheck
he brings home around four thousand a
month and i take an extra two
and put it on the house
along with the payment to pay that off
so my question is
is
should i continue to do that what is
your list because
we have 24 000 in
emergency fund and we have about 375
in retirement
okay
all right
um
all right you um
you are obviously the uh the detail
person
uh and because the way you've discussed
every bit of this everything is absolute
um
that's okay no that's a good thing i'm
just it's just easy to communicate with
you because i'm the same way so
um
the uh
we call them nerds around here and we
love nerds by the way so because i'm
that way so uh but but uh
so there's i i think there's probably
some another play that's actually going
to occur here
okay i think you're going to get a
second opinion on the your husband's
uh ability to engage into work uh 375
000 with a paid off house is okay to
retire with
not super great though
it's better than nothing but it's not
it's not like it's automatic and you
don't have to worry about life or
anything like that so
i would think that he's probably going
to work a couple more years somewhere
else in a less stressful environment
that is approved by the medical
professionals um and that income will go
ahead and get your house paid off
meanwhile you need to keep putting money
into the 401 k and growing it and so
yeah we are doing that if we can get we
have the full 15 if we can get another
three to five years out of this which is
what your original plan was
um your 375 is gonna become 500 plus
what you add to it probably gonna become
six or seven hundred now i'm feeling a
lot more comfortable and the house gets
paid off i obviously don't want to
cause him to have a heart problem by me
putting a lash on his back and saying he
needs to keep working but i think some
kind of work at a maybe even the same
pay at a different environment is
probably going to be okay
and i also want to
agai i know calling the show it's it's
nervous when you when you
when you get on the air and you've got
these lists that you've you rattled off
so i want to speak too much into your
life here but
the way you presented your husband's
heart issue
was a real inconvenience to this plan
you have
and i'm telling you everything's going
good to lay at the paper until he hit
the pavement he screwed up all my plans
and i would tell you
that is a recipe for a stressful home
environment as well
and so maybe consider looking at your
husband as
and i know you do this but as
a close friend who suffered something
hard and it's scary and let's sit in
that for a minute it scared her too it
scared her to death and then let's
figure out what what comes next you may
have to go to work he may have to work
less whatever that looks like but you
live in absolutes let's soften things up
a little bit and just grieve get these
edges get these edges rolled over a
little
he screwed up this time dave
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five
two two five chris and chloe are on the
line in jacksonville florida it says on
my screen you guys are debt free way to
go guys
how much did you think how much did you
pay off
uh forty seven thousand dollars forty
seven thousand ninety dollars good job
and how long did this take
21 months wow and your range of income
during that time
58 000 to one hundred and twenty five
thousand well there's a nice jump
what'd you guys do to double your income
so uh my wife she graduated college so
she got a job um and then on top of that
we did a whole bunch of door dashing
ubereats i did uh some
freelance software development on the
side as well wonderful
so uh what do you guys do living
i'm a graphic designer and i'm a
software engineer all right very good
good for you what kind of debt was the
47 000
oh everything student loans car loans we
had cell phones
disney passes
wow a little bit of everything amazing
okay so did you get out of school chloe
21 months ago then
yeah uh well no you started it before
you got out of school that's what
happened before i got out of school um
and then we actually paid the last three
semesters of my schooling in cash so how
much uh how long have you guys been
married
um
four and a half years okay so what
happened 21 months ago that made you
push start
so actually we were sitting in church
one day listening to a sermon on money
and um we felt really convicted about uh
not tithing it was something
had had some disagreements on and we're
both really scared about it because um
we had pretty much no money at the end
of the month um to the point where we
were actually putting rent on the credit
card just trying to make ends meet
because of the hole that we dug ouch and
so we were sitting there and um we
decided to trust god and we made our
first tithes together and prayed god
we're not asking for more money just to
make this happen
um and it's crazy because a couple days
later literally after in church my best
friend had called me and we were talking
and
we got on the subject of how our old car
was about to die and i was like there's
no way that we can afford a car payment
like i don't know what to do
and she's like stop stop
like no no card payment like just just
listen hear me out have you heard of
dave ramsey and i was like no
and she's like he's this really cool guy
um and please read total money makeover
and
it's just history oh wow
yep
that's exciting and he she your friend
yells like dave does that's fantastic
and so then who sat down with who and
had this conversation
so she actually
talked to me about the book and then we
would listen to the book on our way to
uh disney with um like it was a nice
long trip to like uh be able to listen
to the uh your book and um then from
there we kind of started working on it
how convicting of it what was it to
drive to disney world on disney passes
that you bought with a credit card
listening to total money makeover
oh yeah it was so bad that has to be a
painful drive yeah
it was
oh my gosh
that takes a little of the bu that's a
buzzkill
for sure want to go to space oh whatever
yeah i don't know who cares now oh well
way to go guys i'm so proud of y'all
okay yeah this is amazing you're very
fun so uh what
uh what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is you did it
i think
for me the biggest thing is just the
budget like it was it's amazing to me
how
freeing it was um to be on a budget um
just like it really makes the whole
thing work and for me i'd say
my biggest motivator was my why
and my why was changing my family tree i
grew up super poor
and i didn't want to
have our future children live up in an
environment like that i wanted to own a
home and have you know financial peace
stability and i mean
this these baby steps have allowed us to
do that we actually just completed baby
step three and two weeks ago we moved
into a brand new home you know less than
a quarter of our take-home pay
wow
guys yeah i like it well done well
played well played excellent excellent
job
this is so fun proud of you good good
work very good work hey we got a copy of
uh the baby steps millionaire's brand
new book brand new bestseller and uh how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth and how you can too
that's your next chapter in your story
going and be millionaires now that's
pretty fun and of course then we're also
going to give you another copy of the
total money makeover for you to give
away to someone and uh cause a ruckus
like your friend did with you you can
yell stop it
very cool chris and chloe jacksonville
florida 47 thousand dollars paid off in
21 months making 58 to 125. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're debt-free
yeah yeah
[Applause]
that is fun
yeah every january we get hundreds of
calls from people who are ready to start
fresh like those guys
ready to get control
and i i'm you know trying to find a plan
trying to figure out what to do next and
the plan that has worked for millions
and millions of people is called
financial peace university
it's our class that that has been taught
for years and of course updated we just
updated the uh some of the videos the
other day there'll be brand new ones
coming out in uh several of the lessons
for those of you that are coordinators
and leading people through be be looking
for some new stuff on you on the way
and uh um dr john deloney did a new
lesson for financial peace university
that's absolutely amazing he can't wait
for you to see that you did that with
george yeah it's good stuff and so um
the whole step-by-step plan to get out
of debt save money become outrageously
generous
and uh like that couple there they just
wanted they just want to figure out a
way to tithe i want to figure out a way
to make it work and still eat you know
and we can walk you through how to do
that ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu
you can have a free
trial to ramsey
plus
and um ramsey plus i'll tell you i'll
show you exactly what to do and
financial peace university is a part of
that you can get in the every dollar app
premium version and get going so that's
ramsey solutions dot com
slash fpu financial peace university be
sure and check that out hey that last
call uh the debt free scream i i want to
not blow by something
they went
from a conversation with their friend
about hey our car is dying and i don't
know what we're gonna do
to 21 months later
they paid off their debt that which is
incredible but they doubled their income
through getting a new job in side
hustles
and there's this moment of despair when
so many people i talk to are
collectively there right now like what
do we do
and then it's
oh we can do something and we can do a
little bit more and we can push a little
bit harder and let's go try this and i'm
going to do this and i'm going to sleep
tomorrow because i got to get this done
and they look up and they doubled their
household income data and they bought a
house and they bought a home
it went from worried about they're
worried about how they're going to buy a
car and the net result is debt-free and
buying a house and i'm in in thinking
about it
they took action they took action and
they took action six bucks at a time a
doordash at a time
not i gotta go get make a hundred
thousand dollars i gotta they did it
doordash by doordash by doordash she got
another job which was great
but they nickel and dime the way they
they to
not not poke fun but they baby steps
their way to this thing and we overthink
getting out of despair it's got to be
this big rainbow it doesn't it's got to
be one step and then another one and
then another one
it's incredible
there's
you know you talk about this all the
time the physical changes the
physiological changes and they don't
happen within action no
when you take action even if you're
unsure
even if you're
just i'm a little bit desperate even if
you but but you're at least
impacting the situation instead of
making letting the situation impact you
yeah there's something starts to be
released inside your body inside your
brain inside your spirit and you end up
moving the money around and despair
lifts yeah with action the cloud goes
yeah this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america it's a
free call at triple eight eight two five
five two two five jordan's with us in
little rock arkansas hi jordan how are
you
dave i'm doing great how are you better
than i deserve what's up
uh so i just went through your financial
piece
university and the legacy journey
and it was awesome great
and uh my question for you is kind of
following in your footsteps
how do you become a billionaire
a billionaire
yes sir i've heard you say that's one of
your goals and
i know you said like mutual funds won't
get you there and it's
kind of capped at like five million or
something like that
no it's nice
it's not capped at that but
what i said was was that we've just done
this book baby steps millionaires and
the difference in a million and a
billion is a billion is a thousand
million so
you know you can become a millionaire
everybody can uh without a doubt using
your 401k and funding it generously like
following the baby steps and then
getting your house paid off and that's
the typical way people become
millionaires uh the first one to five
million is what i was saying on that it
doesn't cap at that but
um
there's only so much though that you can
put into a 401k
and uh
so there's only so much you're going to
have in a 401k so you're not going to
get to
a hundred million dollars in your 401k
it's not it's not mathematically
possible so uh and that would only be a
tenth of a billion
so the typically now i don't uh i'm not
an expert on billionaires i am on
millionaires uh i have studied them and
i've looked at the numbers a lot uh i'll
tell you what i generally see
uh all the forbes 400 is now
billionaires there's no nobody no one in
the force 400 that's not at least of
worth a billion at least one billion um
and
bezos is hundreds of billions i mean
it's crazy so
but uh the vast majority uh 70 of the
forbes 400 the wealthiest people in
america
uh first generation meaning they earned
it from nothing
and so they didn't inherit it that's
good news so that means a lot of you got
a shot at it um
the billionaires that i have personally
met and i've probably met now
in person uh
25 or 30 and i've you know studied and
read about a lot of the others the vast
majority of them made their money in
a business
they created a thing they created a
thing okay so you look at michael dell
okay you look at uh true and kathy or
bill gates you look at bill gates you
look at uh
oprah winfrey these are business people
that created a business that became very
very large and so the vast majority of
my wealth beyond
the first 10 million net worth that i
made has been from the business ramsey
solutions
gotcha so is that something where it's
like you need to take a company public
kind of thing
could or don't have to
uh chick-fil-a's not public ramsey
solutions is not public
uh
hobby lobby is not public and david
green would be on that list
do you kind of still hold the same
principles with like
financing businesses like that i don't
finance anything no we're starting
something like no there's no there's no
there's no indication debt caused them
to become a billionaire
uh but what it was some kind of a
they were adding value to the
marketplace they're adding value to the
community and people paid them for it so
they they you know bill gates uh you
know most famous example kim comes up
with a personal computer right apple you
know uh uh is not attributed to a
singular person but
where you're adding value your the a
good or a service that you are bringing
is
uh extremely valuable um elon musk you
know is um
uh adding value uh with the tesla and
spacex and so on and
uh so these people and a lot of them are
people you might not be household names
like we're mentioning those are all
multi-billionaires but the first 1
to 10 billion even
uh
an unusual number of them did it with a
business
i can't i don't have actual facts on it
in terms of i can show you percentages
or i've i've broken it down or i've done
detailed research but that's just
anecdotally looking at it and saying
okay who's on that list
where'd their money come from and you
just kind of do it that way and uh it's
kind of a common sense approach to the
repeat
to the first round of what could become
detailed research but i doubt i'll do
detailed research on a billionaire
where did the narrative come
that
if you were wealthy it's because you did
nothing and someone gave it to you
because it the data in your book
says that's false it's just simply
inaccurate and then i had never even
thought about the billionaires
that i'm sure there's saudi princes and
whatever and it but
these folks like man talk about right
place the right time the world shuts
down and i got this little company
called amazon that deliver stuff to your
door yeah you know what i mean yeah like
they created something of value yep and
and that's where the money comes from
you know it's the
someone got helped someone got served
someone got entertained yeah and that's
where the money comes from but this
narrative is that well the narrative is
marxism i mean you cannot support
communism as a as an economic
methodology
uh
unless you first have to lay the
groundwork and say
uh
that that
all of the wealth the the aristocracy
that has the wealth are evil
and so it must be taken away from them
you have to vilify you got to be
somebody back and the problem is is in
america that the the people that they're
vilifying are successful people and the
problem is they're successful helping
other they're helping other people and
so the narrative won't hold water in
america because people are walking
around going no i know that guy he's not
i know that gal yeah they're not i don't
hate oprah
you know i'm sorry you know you can't
it's not it's not legal to hate oprah
you know it's not so i mean you can't
you can't you know i'm not
you can't go okay kill all the rich
people you know like a uh you know the
russian revolution right
and uh which was brought on by marxism
i'm brought on by communism so you
whether it's that level of violence or
not you can't in order to say
that that
life is unfair and so we have to have
anarchy we have to change the whole
system of economics to one where
everyone is equal right okay uh the only
way that that works is you have to first
vilify
the ones that have the money those who
are above the the bell curve are evil
yeah that's how they got and you know if
they if they were uh russian aristocrats
in 1901
you could go back and probably prove
that they were
inbred evil and had no reason for having
the money the money was handed to them
and they brought provided no value to
the community so it was a lot easier to
get mad at them kill them all right and
karl marx you know steps up right and so
that's uh uh
that but but the problem or hate him
jeff bezos drops boxes off at my house
well he doesn't i know he has his
somebody do it for him yeah but but i
mean he provides me with the surface
whether you like him or not you know a
lot of people use what he has yeah and
uh whether you like bill gates or not or
whether you like you know uh
the whole microsoft movement versus the
apple movement or whatever all that
doesn't matter uh it doesn't matter
bottom line is is the personal computer
has changed the world right
you and i have things sitting on my desk
here that filled a room
uh just a generation ago the the brain
power and so and those men the michael
dells and the women are involved in
these things in silicon valley
and they brought value right now are
there robber barons out there yeah of
course
everywhere though but by and large
they're not the norm right the norm and
so you have to say you have to vilify
success and it just is it's they're
having trouble doing that in america
because the data is against them that's
yeah the data is so clear it's very
clear yeah and so you go okay
uh you know
how can you make it without some jesus
chicken i mean you gotta have
chick-fil-a right so um
it's like a it's a you you know if you
don't have some every so often you're
just not okay so it's uh they serve a
lot of people with the fastest service
at a drive-through anywhere right and
high-quality hot food and they're kind
and wonderful teenagers working there
that know manners and wear a belt and
it's pretty amazing
and um you know so it's you know
how you gonna vilify that right uh well
you have to
if you want to tear it down
first have to make it bad if you want to
tear it down
and that
and the problem is it's a lie it's not
true it's nice it's not true and so it
won't hold water it's not it doesn't
work here
so you wealth inequality people
sorry you're going to take your
communism to a different continent it's
not going to work here this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host he is the
author of the best-selling book
redefining anxiety and the host of the
dr john dolone show both are a must
reads and must listens for you you need
to be sure you check them out we're here
to talk about your relationships
your work
and your money your life
right in front of you taylor is with us
in little rock arkansas hey taylor
what's up
oh how's it going guys thanks so much
for taking my call sure how can we help
well i am uh i've been following your
baby steps for a few years now i'm hook
line and sinker on it uh follow all
y'all's content i'm on step four five
and six
so during this time it allowed me to uh
craig enough margin that i could make a
career change i took ken's advice and
read the book and made the change and
i'm one year into a three-year plan
so basically previously i was an hourly
employee
and now i'm basically building up a book
of business so during that time i have a
three-year
time period where i have a salary i'm
curious if you should uh if you would
recommend i continue the baby steps
saving into retirement during this time
or if i should kind of hold up a little
extra cash preparing for that transition
from a salary you know form a payment to
where i'm basically self-employed
when are you going to be making this
jump
um so basically i'm one year into a
three-year plan yeah where's the firm
i'm at i'm actually i'm actually an
investment advisor now so i don't know
how many financial advisors have called
your show that may be a good thing or a
bad thing
but okay uh so i've got i've got 24
months to go with this base salary um
i'm on track uh oh you you didn't make
the career change but the salad you're
changing from salary that they give you
a starter salary until you get your book
of business built enough to live on or
hopefully get you correct okay so how's
the
you're one year in
before and you have two years left on
the starter salary so
how's the book building is it coming
together it's on track yes it's on track
um everything of course you know this
business everything i hear is how hard
it is and how yeah i listen to what you
guys say it takes twice as long as you
think it's going to it's you know you're
not the exception i mean where are you
today do you have do you actually have
people in that are where you're making
an ongoing income
that's equal to your salary yet
uh i'm not equaling my salary yet no no
when i met with my supervisors they tend
to say yes i'm i'm i'm growing at the
rate they would expect me to so that at
the end of this three years i'm not
asking about meeting their expectations
about a dollar amount if you went off
the salary today what would your income
be
oh well i i i'm not anywhere near that
sour i don't even have any idea yet so
basically nothing i'm talking
oh no i would be i would be earning an
income but it's basically it's probably
less than twenty percent of what i
expected that's what i'm asking for
years ago oh no not expect to be able to
make i ask you're on a 24 000 salary and
you're making it on that right now okay
now i guess i'd i guess i explained my
situation wrong that's not i'm on a 50
i'm on a 50 000 salary right now okay
you're on a 50 000 salary and you're
making it okay on that so if your book
of business generates fifty thousand
dollars you wouldn't skip a beat when
you lose the salary right
that's right so are you at now what what
is the book of business creating today
ten thousand dollars of the fifty two
thousand dollars of the fifty or forty
thousand dollars of the fifty roughly
ten thousand
ten dollars okay that's what i'm asking
so gauge that
and the uh the the more as you i would
go another year for and not worry about
it after another year okay if you're not
looking like you're gonna make it to 50
then maybe you do need to stop your baby
steps but right now you're worried about
something hadn't happened yet
right that's true yeah i just i didn't
want to reach the end of this three-year
trek and no i don't want you to either
but you're only one year in
true
so run it another year and you'll be
able to tell you know if you're at 12-5
after another year well yeah we got a
problem
yeah exactly okay but if you're at 42.5
after another year i think you're
probably gonna make it you don't have to
even ask this question then right yeah
and let those guys
let those guys who are giving you pats
on the back or saying yeah you're on
track i i i haven't you have no idea
what their motives are you have a dollar
amount right in front of you that will
tell you yeah that's true here's how i'm
doing now pat's on the back aren't your
scorecard your credit card's the money
that's right uh and it's not because
we're all about money but this
discussion is about your income and so
you know
can you make it or not make it that's it
it's it's a it's a it is an objective
not a subjective situation so you can
actually measure it and go i'm either
there or i'm not or i'm close enough
that i can make it that kind of thing
thomas with us in green bay wisconsin
high thelma welcome to the that's not it
and i can't get rid of hey there we go
my bad i pushed the wrong button selma's
in green bay how are you thelma
i'm doing good and i'm very nervous um
good to talk to you dave and john and
i want to say what would dave do but i
know they wouldn't be in my position
well he might have been one time you
never know what you got kiddo lots of
dumb okay um i just started with you
like six months ago just listening and
stuff because
i got like two years before i'm eligible
to retire
um
but i may have to go longer okay so
my husband and i
started
uh with time shares back in 2000
and we kept buying more and kept buying
more into buying more okay you have more
than one
what how many do you have
well if we have like a million points
with windom okay
and so that's what we kept buying more
windham
um
playing the dumb game we love to travel
don't have the money to travel
um
and we thought this would be great for
our kids
thoughts okay so anyway i had a
conversation with them today and they
have a program where they would actually
just of course take your property back
you owe them nothing
um because in their eyes i have the
contracts paid off
but i only have it paid off because we
got personal loans and loan you know
equity loans
to actually pay them off okay so we
still owe
i couldn't tell you with that when we
combine everything we had credit cards
and everything we have like 16 60 000 in
loans
okay
they would give us this they would take
the property back
in two different sections either we just
give it all back and walk away
and
see nothing
or we give it back and we get three
years of our million points to use
amongst
um my husband and our four children
um because we have our children on the
contract
with their names so what's your question
what what's your question
the question is
with a 643 maintenance fee on this on
these points for the rest of our lives
would you give it back yes and just say
i'm stupid and i don't want nothing to
do yeah yes
i know when my husband and i because
we're new at this and we're doing the
budget
you're tired of the fees and the fees
aren't going anywhere but up with
wyndham
time timeshare is legalized fraud
it is an absolute
completely screw job
and yeah i'd get out of it walk away
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
well it's time to put
2021 behind us last year we left a lot
of people feeling burned out and
sluggish
beat up beat down
despair but 2022 is a fresh start and
it's your wake-up call are you ready to
own this year grab it by the ears and
make it behave come on now time to get
goals going with your money your career
your life get we got the plan to get you
there it's our new year's sale right now
check it out 73 off our best-selling
books assessments and envelopes includes
the brand new bestseller baby steps
millionaires how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
it'll show you the quickest right way to
become a millionaire or if you're
looking for a better way to manage your
cash especially in categories that blow
up your budget like food or whatever
check it out we've got the essential
cash envelope system to help you a lot
of these books and items are now 10
bucks right now all kinds of goodies
going on right now to help you at the
new year at ramseysolutions.com
backslash store our question today comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure or you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
window blinds for free free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
always use the magic word the promo code
ramsey
all right today's question comes from
brendan in rhode island brendan writes
i've worked hard for eight years after
completing graduate school at age 23.
i paid off 14 grand in student loans and
a 13 000 car note i'm 31 now and i make
100 grand a year as a cpa i have 80
grand in cash 140 in retirement savings
i bought a condo on which i owe 122 at
3.15
i'm doing well but i could be doing
better i have money hoarding issues
which are debilitating even on smaller
purchases i worry about money more than
i should for my level of success my
investments are 15 in bonds because i'm
afraid of a dip and cannot bring myself
to invest in excess cash a six month
emergency fund for me would be 15 to 17
grand how do i get myself out of this
hoarding and fear in order to boost my
financial success
i
right off the top here man this question
i'm doing well but i could be doing
better
often folks get tied up in this
elusive
place where they're gonna quote unquote
feel a certain way whenever they get to
some sort of finish line
and most of us don't take the time to
articulate to ourselves what that
feeling is going to feel like and so we
make our first million i haven't made
one but
then you just you're so obsessed with
the next one because you never stop to
think you think this is gonna heal you
right and you don't ever get there and
so i'd love this to ask to sit back and
say what are you chasing what are you
running from where do you think you're
gonna be what's it gonna feel like when
you get to wherever you think you're
going because this person is just on a
treadmill hitting up and up and up and
up and up
and yet very intellectually self-aware
brilliant self-aware yes because the
language you're using says you know
that that you're but i can't say that
you're not that you're not in a good
place it has nothing to do with the math
it has nothing to do with the money it's
a spiritual issue that's right godliness
with contentment
is great gain
i want you to kind of what i would tell
you to do is to step back and say let's
start viewing money
through a spiritual lens
through a
a behavior lens
that says
all right i've got to put it over there
it's a tool
i'm not freaked out about my car my car
is a tool that gets me to my job and
gets me to the store and i don't sit and
worry about and obsess about my car
money's a tool it's taking me somewhere
it's a vehicle it's taking me somewhere
and it's sitting over there
instead of it's in my heart
hoarding is a word you use if it's in
your heart
and uh it's compulsive i can't yeah the
this is all it's
like it's got its claws in you yeah and
so the peace that passes understanding
yes is what we're looking for i want you
to reach a place where the money is
sitting over here and you're looking at
it in a pile smiling at it
and breathing in cool mountain air
and that sense of
exhale and just kind of
okay we're all right and that's
contentment for me as a spender
brendan what i i i experience that a
couple different ways one way i laugh
about when i experience it is
i used to think when you went into
costco or sam's that it was federal law
you had to spend 200 that's why they
checked you going out with the thing
they want to make sure you spend your
200 right i i just i it was a frenetic
need
to buy something
i think and it wasn't a sickness i
wasn't obsessive compulsive but it was
just a it was a spiritual maturity thing
and it's like oh if i get that i'll be
better if i get that i'll be better
forget that'll be better and what you
were talking about a minute ago john and
so uh
something happened and uh
when i walk in there now i don't i can
buy anything in there or everything in
there and i don't
buy any of it and leave quite often yeah
and so it's just that that's a i put it
over there your safety your safety
target has moved yeah it's what i'm
trying to you're asking money to do
something it can't do right
it can't give you peace
it can't give you wholeness it can't
give you
uh no risk right there's no such thing
and so
when you do that that helps and then
you know
john always says when you're dealing
with trauma that facts are your friends
and so let's let's look at what's real
here yeah okay and you say okay what's
real is bonds are going to underperform
in your portfolio and you're actually
going to make a mess
instead of actually made good money on
something that has a very long
stable track record i mean there are
mutual funds that are 80 years old that
have had
eight down years in 80 years and 72 up
years so
to fret over that kind of track record
is to fret over real estate going up or
let's let's call that what it is if
uh mutual funds go away
you'll be dealing with much bigger
issues in your life yeah right you'll
you'll be borrowing water from your
neighbors so there'll be a bigger
bullets and others
that's right you'll be trading blue
jeans yeah so yeah so so you know yes
you need to
loosen up i i think you're trying to
make the money do to to
warm blanket do something spiritually
for you that it doesn't have the
capability to do and you mentioned the
word trauma often it's been a while
since i've been in the hoarding
literature but if i remember correctly a
lot of hoarding stems from loss or from
trauma that hasn't been dealt with and
it's just your body's way of trying to
grab control of something until suddenly
that control takes a hold of you well
and the truth is one thing money can do
is it can give you a pad yeah between
life
and yeah you know problems i mean you
know if the car blows up and you've got
some money it's different than if the
car blows up you don't have money so the
truth is it does control the can helps
you control the controllables but what
it cannot do is it cannot make you
breathe that cool mountain air into your
soul and so this sentence i'm doing well
but i could do better i want you to
spend some time
where are you trying to go like where is
this this imaginary finish line and what
do you think it's going to feel like
when you get there
just spend some time with that breathe
out here and i love that dave larry
burkett used to say that the only
difference between saving and hoarding
his attitude huh
the same amount of money yeah yeah and
it's the same action yeah it's how it's
how tight you're holding you right now
it's attitude it's how you feel
about the money and what you're asking
the money to do for you is it going to
save me protect me keep me warm and
fuzzy at night hoarder that's a hoarder
that's exactly right yeah and that's i
need you know so i can't get rid of this
stack of magazines that i've had for 73
years you know i'm a hoarder and and you
know your house looks like a a dump
because you can't you can't get rid of
this stuff because it's supposed to do
something for you that it doesn't have
the ability to do so this weekend i had
i had a suit that my granddad gave me
before he passed away
and it fits me
um but it's a it's an older cut so it's
not something you could wear
um i say it fits me it doesn't fit me
great but it did and i've kept it i've
never put it on in a decade other than
just to
just to try it on once or twice and this
weekend i started i was cleaning out an
old closet and i started to get rid of
it and i was like no this is my
granddad's suit who passed away and i
finally said my granddad is not in this
ill-fitted old suit he's here yeah right
and it's time for this to go because
this was i was trying to get this suit
to do something to be a memory it's not
its job it can't do stuff it's to get me
out of a bank if you give it that job
it's going to fail at it every time the
money's going to fail that's right at
making you feel that cool mountain air
into your soul financial peace is an
attitude it is not an amount
yeah a load of amount that's the thing
that's a good question great question
man very good question this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
fifth
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr chondaloni ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five
javon is with us in charlotte north
carolina hey javon what's up
hey dave so
we had a lot of medical expenses coming
up this year and so i switched from an
fsa
to an hsa because i wanted the higher
limits to cover those things and not
have to come out of pocket however
i was no i did not realize it was i
explained to me that the hsa is not
front loaded
like the ffa so we are on baby step two
and
i would like to double our contributions
so that we have money to roll over to
next year and then we can reduce them
but because my baby step two i don't
want to do that so i'm just trying to
figure out um how would you navigate
that with because i wasn't really
planning on paying for things like i
have a monthly budget because we have
made to save but there's no money in it
because it's january
okay so when are the bills coming
um i got a tooth field yesterday and
that was like a hundred dollars and um
i went to fight my card and there was
any money in it because my husband's
first paycheck was the friday before
and the contributions hadn't actually
hit yet
okay
but how
uh what are what are the medical bills
that are ongoing that are so large
they're not um like ongoing uh my
husband needs some implants my daughter
is supposed to need some implants so
she's missing some permanent
they're talking about doing braces this
year and
just looking at our portion for the
implants that was going to be over the
limit of the ssa by itself and i didn't
want the hsa is covering all this dental
yeah it's good for a dental yeah the fsa
is like 2700
and like if we got all four implants
this year no the hsa is a health
plan
it's not a dental plan you can work
you can buy it you can pay dental out of
your h out of your health savings
account but your your your health plan
likely doesn't cover dental
yes but the hsa i can use those funds
for dental oil
i know that yeah
okay but your your flexible savings
account is just a that's just the
cafeteria plan where they take your
money out pre-tax and you can label what
you want to use it for and you can use
it for anything for your out-of-pocket
costs on anything right
i don't know why you couldn't do both
well
i guess his company won't allow us to do
both we have to do either or
um and we've already made our elections
because you know open enrollment was
last year but um after switching i
didn't like i called our
administrator for the hsa and they told
me that the hsa is not going to be front
loaded with the funds okay the money
going into the hsa
out of your husband's check
is um
just is making it a pre-tax
contribution into the hsa and then when
you spend the money out of the hsa for
medical there's no taxes on it so all
you're saving by all of this is the
taxes on the amount that's all you're
saving
yes other than what insurance is
covering and are not covering in the two
competing plans but the idea of your hsa
the actual health savings account not
being funded the only thing that costs
you is taxes
oh i should be you're you're saying so
you just write a hundred dollar check
and you didn't get the tax benefit is
all but on the cafeteria plan if if
you're gonna
have 5 000 bucks that five grand is
available to you january 2nd and you're
saying that five grand in the hsa won't
be available to you until the end of the
year when you've already
funded it until you've funded it
gradually okay but no it'll be fun not
the end of the year it's incrementally
you're funding it out of your husband's
check right correct yeah okay so it's
just incrementally going to grow through
the time so the only time you've got a
problem is if you have a bill bigger
than you've been month than the amount
you've been monthly putting in total
yes that's the only time you have a
problem which is today because it's
january and you ain't even got any money
in there and you had 100 bills so you
just pay that 100 bill
just write them a check or you wait and
pay it next month out of the hsa one or
two just pay don't pay them until next
month
oh yeah they weren't accepting that they
were like what's your debit card right
now
so yeah that's so that's what i was
thinking i was thinking either to just
pay it out of our budget which means
that's less money going towards it and
then at the end of the year send in all
of the receipts but it sounds like
it sounds like you're doing a whole lot
of business with this dentist
and it sounds like that they can wait a
month for their money
what you described to me was thousands
and thousands of dollars of dental work
through your whole family
yeah like i said my husband needs two
implants in my job so i think your
dentist is gonna change his attitude or
i'm gonna change my dentist especially
with hsa which is essentially you're
paying with cash yeah you can wait a
month because i gotta get this thing
funded yeah and they can wait ain't
gonna kill them on a hundred dollar bill
when they're get when you're doing
thousands of dollars of business with
them yeah they can wait or i'll get a
new dentist that's right they treat me
like i'm somebody off the street and i
gotta pay cash on the barrel head
because you think i'm gonna stiff you
and yet you've got me lined up for
implants here and implants there and
everything oh my god no
don't have an attitude with me
just because you got a medical doctor
because you've got a white coat on it's
not a good idea
so um we'll get you paid these little
white coats are there a problem we'll
get you paid open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five thank
you for joining us dave is in salt lake
city hey dave welcome to the ramsey show
thank you so much how are you better
than i deserve what's up
um
well before i knew about you and your
program i took some loans off my 401k
and
after reading your book i i really need
to make a plan i'm a complete mess but
i'm paying like hundred dollars a month
uh and low to pay these loans back in my
401k and
um
obviously i took you know some advice
from people who didn't really know and
those same people have no idea how to
help me get out of this math i'm just
curious if there's any
any way to that i can um
use
the 401k to like pay these loans off or
something to get out
from them like
how much do you owe on your 401k
uh 40
thousand dollars
yes geez what'd you do with it
uh home improvement stuff paid off some
other debt just to get myself in debt
again
okay so how much debt have you got not
counting your house today
um
she
will be actually that would be 40 as
well
okay so 80 000 makes you debt free not
counting your house
correct and what do you what do you make
what's your household
income uh about 111
okay so how fast you're going to pay off
80 making 111
uh
my goal was for two years there you go
um
but i like i said i don't need so what
is the other 40 is it the other 40s on
what
uh
there was a home equity loan and then
there was uh um
some credit cards no car
uh no cars are paid for good ironically
what are they worth
uh total probably only about 15 grand
what's the boat worth there's an suv
what's that what's the boat worth
i don't have a boat okay just checking
it's a good test
my only uh my guilty pleasure is my
riding mower and it's paid for two so
okay all right so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna get
on a detailed written plan
beans and rice rice and beans
you're not going on vacation until you
get this mess cleaned up you're not
going out to eat until you get this mess
cleaned up you're gonna get out the
scissors and have a plastic surgery
party tonight and chop up all your
credit cards
you gotta you gotta fix this and it's
gonna require you get radical for the
first time in your life you've been
slopping around on this subject for a
decade and you're sick of looking at
yourself in the mirror
on how it's turned out
am i right how did you know that no
because i'm you i did it too
i know exactly how it feels
so yeah a lot of what you were saying to
other people was that with the
spiritual issue i've never really
addressed it in that hand yeah yeah and
this is time in your case it's time to
get mad
sick and tired of being sick and tired
i'm disgusted and i'm not living like
this
any more and that's when people lose
weight and that's when they fix their
marriage and that's when they fix their
money and i'm gonna put you into
financial peace university and hook you
up with every dollar with a ramsay plus
subscription
and get you set up man and show you
exactly how to do this stuff the only
thing i ask is
by god you go do it if i give you all
this stuff for free
and then you go help somebody else when
you're rich someday and you will be if
you follow it this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five thanks
for joining us lucas is with us in
croatia okay hey lucas how are you
hey i'm doing well how are you better
than i deserve croatia as in the country
yes sir wow okay cool how can we help
um so i'm getting ready to move out of
my parents house and
a long story short i just want to know
your best
advice for me as
you know getting ready to move out and
move back to the states buy myself a car
stuff like that what is your
best advice for someone like me
um getting ready to get into a lot of
financial
um
you know
uh you know responsibilities and um
basically what what can i do
now and you know whenever i do move out
to set myself up for a better future and
uh you know
a financially free future okay so you're
an american in croatia and you're coming
back to america leaving your parents
house
and your parents are living in croatia
yes sir we're missionaries okay and how
old are you
i'm 16.
and you're coming back to the states
when
um
so either this summer or about this time
next year
okay as a minor
where are you going to live yeah yes sir
i'll be living in oklahoma city with um
some buddies in mind
and if that doesn't work out then i'll
move down to texas with my brother
okay because you've got your the problem
you're going to run into it and if
you're not 18 is you're not going to be
able to transact business
you can't sign a lease
yes sir you
are you gonna come in i'm sorry
that's where my buddies that are older
than me are gonna come in and sign a
lease and then there's gonna be
basically a mutual agreement among us
yeah and what are you gonna be doing for
a living
uh well in the beginning i'm going to be
going to a bible college in oklahoma
city and then um
probably working at chick-fil-a honestly
because it's got the highest pay for
someone that doesn't have a degree yet
and then after that i'm honestly not too
sure
um
i believe that maybe after that i'll
probably move to alaska because i love
up there so it's um
yeah but then maybe go to another
college possibly it just depends on
um you know what the lord wants me to do
honestly you're an adventurous dude okay
um
so uh you're gonna make enough money at
chick-fil-a to go to bible college pay
rent and eat
yes sir
yeah after taxes it'll be about 14 an
hour
it'll be about 640 a week
okay and you've already already laid
your budget out
yes sir i have
wow
okay
um wow impressive all right so uh
you know advice would be that to do
exactly what you're doing which is lay a
budget out and at this stage of your
life
and as young as you are going on this
great adventure of yours uh
there's
there's
no way that you could possibly pile up
too much cash
i want you to see how big a pile of cash
extra money in a savings account you can
create a huge emergency fund
i mean you would never get there but if
you had 50 000 sitting in a savings
account with all the things you have
going on in your life
and all the different uh moving parts of
and transitional
stages of your life that you are in
and the things you're talking about
doing and the expense of those
fifty thousand dollars wouldn't be too
much
so and you're not gonna get and you're
probably not gonna get there and that's
okay i'm not saying that has to be the
goal but my point is simply pile up cash
and live on a written plan that that has
margin in it that allows you to pile up
cash the bigger pile of cash you have
the more options you're going to have
and uh you're coming out of the
missionary family so the bible says in
the house of the wise
are stores
of choice food and oil in proverbs
okay
so wise people save money and uh you are
wise beyond your years and you are
adventurous and you're taking on
quite a deal here for a 16 year old guy
why are you leaving home yesterday
um so i'm finished almost finished with
school and honestly there's there's a
there's not much other reason for me to
stay here and um of course as you
already stated i'm a very adventurous
and i don't like being held down one
place for too long and um i'm just you
know i'm i'm ready to uh
kind of experience life on my own and
outside of my parents um household
are they in support of their 16 year old
going across the halfway across the
globe to just go figure out life
yes sir they are they've taught me a lot
so
i'll be 17 by the time i move so
i know a lot of 37 year olds that
probably shouldn't be living on their
own so good for you
good for you
[Laughter]
hey me let me also suggest this i want
you to write down some core values that
you have
like about how you're going to treat
people how you're never going to borrow
money
how you're going to
never
um
be dishonest and i want you to hold that
thing close to you
when you're heading on a great big
adventure it's easy to take one step off
of a path because it just is a quick
corner cut and you find yourself way
off the mark
and um
get a set of core values about who you
are who you're going to be make sure you
got some people in your life as you take
on this adventure you can't do life
alone man it's cool in the movies it
just doesn't work that way in real life
yeah yeah it sounds like you've got some
guys that are trustworthy that you're
teaming up with on the first leg of this
and then a brother brother as a backup
and so
um
it's an interesting thing you're doing
dude and um
uh so yeah
again a written game plan writing down
the core values writing down your budget
which you've already started working out
and uh the more you can work the better
uh and pile up some cash too because
that'll give you some options on your
adventures
and uh alaska's not cheap yeah a lot of
things it it is cold and it's not cheap
and bears yeah and they're bearish
[Laughter]
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five chase is with us
in dallas texas hi chase how are you
hey dave thanks for taking my call i
have got a
a pro a good problem uh but a problem
um my grandmother uh just turned 97 she
passed down 10 dollars basically down to
chain of family to each of us relative
um so what do i do with it um this is
the question right now i'm in flight
school
cash flowing flight school i'm expected
to spend
about 75 000 between now and the end of
august
where's that money coming from
uh so that i have saved up over years
and years and years so how much do you
have in saving how much do you have in
savings today
so this uh the savings i'm drawing for
this has about 85 000 in it it's kind of
got a like a 5 000 cushion between the
expenses i'm expecting to
uh incur and just a little bit of wiggle
room there so i put
flight school you're just all in
and you're going to be done in august
and and you're planning your plan
when you plan when you finish is to do
what
uh so after i finish that i'll be a
flight instructor to get up hours until
i can work with the regional airline
okay
all right
and you can live off a flight instructor
salary
uh yeah so i've got a nice split rent uh
three great roommates and a very nice
leaf so okay i would just put the ten
thousand dollars into your
fund
because you have one major goal right
now graduate from flight school
and this you know and after you have
done that if there's money left over
because of x or y and or because you put
the ten thousand dollars in there it
might be fifteen thousand left over
uh there might be twenty thousand left
over because you told me at eighty five
and you need seventy five so you know
then you can decide what you're going to
do with that and where you're gonna how
you're gonna apply to baby steps but
right now
that fund is your lifeline to your goal
it's gonna make your goal happen
and i'm just gonna pad that lifeline
strengthen that lifeline because it's
just from now until august and after
that we'll look and see how much is left
over okay then i'm going to be living on
the flight instructor then i can take
that 20 000 and say all right i'm
debt-free now i'm going to label some of
this my emergency fund or i'm going to
buy a house with whatever the thing is
maybe it's time to upgrade a car or
whatever but but you know label
ten thousand after the emergency fund
they give me ten thousand do something
else in the baby steps but you start
working the baby steps in august with
what's left over
but first let's make sure you get
through and that there's something left
over
follow it handle good question man this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america dr john deloney
best-selling author and host of the dr
john doloni show ramsey personality is
my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life your money
your relationships and your work we're
here for all of that on the ramsey show
roy is with us in morristown new jersey
to start the hour off hey roy what's up
uh hey dave thank you so much for taking
my call um
so i am in a bit of a pickle i am
a 43 year old immigrant
i don't have a college education i just
graduated high school
i was on my own for the longest time
self-employed and
november of 2019 i lost my business
uh then the pandemic hit
then i'll divorce it and i find myself
today
444 000 in debt without any sucks any
income and
with credit card debt i arrest that
child support debt all incurring fees
and interest i'm just not sure where to
start at this point
wow
i'm sorry man you've been through hell
yeah
yeah um you're in it right now aren't
you
where'd you uh yeah
where'd you immigrate from
israel
where
israel israel okay yeah okay
what kind of a business did you have
i owned a small business where i would
buy the uh second-hand phones iphone
from a company called brightstar that
did apple's logistics i would bring them
into my office i would separate them
test them and then refurbish them and
resell them
and why did that not work
oh it worked great for about eight years
and then i got an email from my vendor
from buy star saying that they stopped
that they're going to stop selling the
product because they signed an exclusive
contract with one of my competitors
so you had only one customer
one vendor correct yeah which was the
most reliable because it was basically
everything that was returned to the
apple store or the online store would go
to rights but i didn't do the logistics
so it was the only
um dependable uh
vendor in my market yes how did you come
upon that
opportunity so i've been in the cell
phone business for about
15 years and you know
through a lot of research and just trade
shows
networking i
found brightstar
okay
all right
well and it worked for a while
that's interesting yeah eight years did
very well so what kind of debt is the
444
so we're looking at uh
70 000 in credit card debt we're looking
at 60 000 irs so the irs basically it's
capital gains tax i started investing in
2013
and because my uh i lost my job in 2019
i sold half of my portfolio in late 2019
and so what is the other 200 or 300 000
okay so we have small business loans
from the sba
how am i
428 okay
and then i have uh a current support
order from the judge due to my divorce
at 7 500 a month and he did that
retroactively as of like six months
before and putting me
seventy thousand dollars in debt from
day one
that's back child support
correct well it wasn't really a bachelor
he made it retroactive yes like yeah i
wasn't i wasn't the order to pay one but
david he did order me the pill and he
said okay we're going back seven months
so you got a dollar amount and not a
percentage
i got a dollar been correct
okay but you have no job no income right
now
correct i've been trying um applying
left and right um
my issue is one of my issues is that at
7 500 a month just for support i need to
find a job that pays me over 120 000 a
year with no college education that's a
very tough ask
now what you need is a lawyer yeah uh
because most child support is based on
your income not a set fixed amount and
you need to go back before the judge and
explain and that you know say this is
what i'm making
nothing and when i do get a job your
owner will come back in and we'll set
the percentage by law because every
state does this by percentages was there
something did you do something that's a
that's a stout amount or were you making
just he was making bank a ton of money
before you lost your business no
no so basically what the judge went off
was as uh my wife's attorney was very
savvy and convincing the judge that
the capital gains tax that i was taxed
in 2019 was 250 000
and the same thing for 2020 was 250 000
so she convinced the judge that somehow
i was making a quarter million dollars a
year i'm not sure how the judge
didn't know the difference between
capital gains and earned income but
that's pretty much what he went off yeah
well your your attorney sucked and you
do need a new one and you do need to go
back in there and reset this because
it's not telling you you have to you
can't not it's number one it doesn't
work you can't pay it you don't have any
money and number two uh you can't you
can't set your career up based on your
child support you set your child support
up based on your career
and so that is not your income
and so you've got to get that that
that's a side issue the rest of this
stuff's still sitting there
um and you do need to go make some money
your best shot though at making money is
not going and getting a job it's finding
the next opportunity because you are
you have an eye for things you have an
eye for business you have an
entrepreneurial ability the only thing
you screwed up in your business model
was you depended on one singular
customer one singular vendor for
everything and that gave them the power
to put you out of business that's a lack
of diversification you don't want to do
that you need to build a business model
out that has many many vendors and many
many customers and that way if one of
them goes sideways it doesn't shut you
down it just is an ouchy and so
that's going to be your play i mean you
before you start talking about how
you're going to pay off debt
we have to talk about how we get income
and so you can go get a job if you want
to that's fine and then you go get
before the judge again or a different
judge and with a different attorney and
get these uh numbers reset to a
reasonable amount i'm not about people
not paying child support you need to pay
child support but you also need to pay
the amount that is a percentage of your
income not
some mythical number and this is this is
pretty bizarre
and
also it feels like you made one mistake
back in 2019 and then you borrowed some
money to try to cover that mistake and
then you borrowed some more money to
cover those mistakes
and so man we've got to get to where we
if we have one we fall down we dust
ourselves off and keep on on a path
moving forward we don't just keep piling
on these mistakes man and the next time
you start your business idea you start
it with cash and you run it with cash
not with that that's right because your
some of your credit card debt and your
sba loan had to do with your startup and
some of it had to do with trying to hang
on after you crashed and so
to john's point so you've gotta you
gotta say i'm swearing off of debt for
startup and i'm swearing off of debt for
survival so as a guy you've been through
it what
what's the point when you look in the
mirror and say is bankruptcy right for
me when do you get what what's you don't
have any other way to do it okay and
there's you know it doesn't fix his
situation because the day if he's if he
has zero debt he still has zero income
right
and you go you have to have an income
got a job so we got to go we got to fix
that and the child support's not
bankruptable and neither is the irs
so the only thing to be bankrupting on
is seventy thousand dollars for the
credit card debt
oh the sba is bankrupt but yeah
wow sorry brother
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
thanks for joining us america it's a
free call dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today tanya is
with us tonya is in cincinnati hi tanya
how are you
fine how are you dave y'all hey what's
up
nothing i was calling
because
my husband
died in november
and
before he had died shortly before he had
died we had been listening you guys for
a long time but shortly before he had
died we had saved up our thousands and
um was starting to pay on our own art
but
when he died i had to move in with my
brother
so i'm wondering
um should i be saving to get my own
place right now
or should i continue paying on our debts
that we had
my goodness i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
what happened what happened to him
um he was fighting a drug addiction with
cocaine and um
when he would want to go run off and get
high he would get violent with me so we
got into a fight and then he left and um
got a hold of some drugs that have
fentanyl and overdosed
i'm so sorry
how old are
you i'll be 40 in may
you got kids
no
i had two children that died
okay my goodness
a lot of tragedy
how long ago was that
uh
my first child died in 2012 my second
child died in 2013.
my goodness wow
uh
okay the baby steps are
a process for
prospering
building wealth and so on right now
i can't breathe if i'm you and i'm not
worried about that
i want to get where i can breathe again
first
okay so um are you working do you have a
career
um i did do a paper route for nine years
and i got into it i had quit doing that
and started doing
door dash full time so that's what i do
now
how long have you been doing that
i started doing it when it first came
out just like as a side hustle but
i've been doing it full time now since
september when me and him
got into it
[Music]
it brings in
depending on how i work you know like
during his funeral and stuff like that i
didn't do too good but
usually it's anywhere between eight to a
thousand dollars a week
what do you want to be doing two years
from now and three years from now and
five years from now
um
three years from now i would like to
be in my own place
um
have a nice little cushion where i don't
have to worry about you know if my car
breaks down
uh
breathing again like they said and
five years from now
um
i don't really know five years from now
to be honest i don't really know
okay
um
well
what i would concentrate on right now is
um
the basic necessities of life
food shelter clothing transportation
utilities
and um
so that involves you getting your own
place um
not a huge rush on that because but
you're door dashing and you're making
between 40 and 50 000 a year that's what
you're telling me
okay
and you should be able to run a budget
on that you're living you said you're
living with your brother right
correct
and what's he charging you rent anything
nothing actually it's him his wife three
kids three dogs was there any life
insurance or any money that
was left over okay
no no life insurance we only had our
thousand dollars in the bank and our
paycheck that was coming up following
week
okay
who paid for the funeral
it was collective a whole bunch of
different people in his
family funeral wasn't everybody threw
some money in a hat and we got it done
okay pretty much
all right
well baby girl i'm sorry
um
what i would tell you to do is right now
let you yeah let's let's uh how much
debt do you have
i've got
9 900 student loans 3 900 on an amazon
card 500 on the secured card
500 as a family one to my sister
i've got one payday run paid down to
where i only have that 55 left and i owe
the irs about a thousand
okay all right get the payday lenders
out of your life and never set foot on
that place again okay
they're com they're completely con
artists they're scam
you've got to stop you're going to stay
with 100
yeah and then you need to get the irs
cleaned up as soon as you can
and and then i want you to pile up some
cash and get you get you a little
apartment okay
and let's set up house and then let's
keep working and begin to i guess you
begin to clean these debts up
i don't know why you wouldn't um food
shelter clothing transportation and
utilities survival is first
sustainability is first okay
and a payday lender being gone the irs
being gone is part of that and then
you've got a little an inexpensive
little apartment and you're making 40 or
50 000 a year
and
then you begin to work on your long-term
money goals and work in the baby steps
and you need to you need to begin to
work on your
um
long-term career goals
i'm gonna send you a copy of ken
coleman's book and uh as you're healing
and you're getting where you can breathe
again
uh let's go ahead and read that because
i don't want your door dashing as your
full-time job when you're 50.
right
i mean it's it's it's a wonderful thing
right now because you're making decent
money you're working your butt off
but you're making decent money and you
can survive on it
but it's not i don't think that's your
long-term play is it
i don't
know i've always wanted to open up like
me and my husband
we're talking to a realtor about because
the paper route we used to have we would
get like 20 25 000 and christmas tips
every year so we were going to use that
this year
to put down as a down payment on a home
and i was going to open up a dog candle
for
um like injured dogs and
dogs that needed you know a foster home
to live in temporarily
now there's you start to have some goals
okay you start to think about something
that makes your heart beat again and
doordash doesn't make your heart beat it
puts money puts food on the table and
pays the electric bill but it doesn't
make your heart beat right that's what
we were looking for a while ago in our
earlier question
so um hang on i'll have uh have the guys
pick up and give you a copy of ken's
book but i think first and foremost
you're gonna take care of you you've
been through hell
okay a little bit yeah yeah not a little
bit you have been girl a lot i mean you
got you you got
you you got the crud knocked out of you
here
and you're carrying around a lot so
can i the the folks that have been close
to me in my life that
um
were in relationship with somebody who
was a cocaine addict
i need you to hear me directly okay
you're worth being loved and you're
worth being well and you're worth being
safe
do you believe that
um
i need you to hear me i know i'm worth
being safe
and you're worth being well and you're
worth being loved
and it's been a long long time
since that
have you felt that is that right yeah
people who are addicted to cocaine or
their heart well they're in love with
powder
and nothing else and so they don't show
you any love and it's been a long time
since you've felt that
and then you've got the abandonment to
go with it now
so what a mess what am i so sorry
hang on kiddo we'll walk with you we're
here if you need some help you call back
anytime this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today steph is with us in austin
texas says on my screen you are
debt-free sir what's up
hey how's it going dave good man how
much you pay off
uh 46 000. cool how long did this take
uh totals 16 months good and your range
of income during that time
um it stems from i believe it was like
65 up to about a little over 90. good
good good for you what do you do for a
living
yeah i'm a i'm a sorcerer or a recruiter
for a tech company i thought you said a
sorcerer
i was like sweet
what's the difference i guess
it's like man we just stepped into harry
potter world or something man
a sorcerer okay
okay and um
john
i can't take you anywhere um
i thought he said sorcery i know i heard
you say that yes
but i but i yeah okay so the
46 000 in debt what kind of debt was
that
yeah all of it or not but most of it was
my student loans i believe uh 35 000 was
in student loans and then uh the rest
was in my uh my vehicle cool how old are
you
uh 27 now yeah
good good all right so what happened 16
months ago that woke you up plugged you
into this ramsey stuff
yeah um covered
yeah that's really what happened uh you
know got uh scared straight huh yeah for
real that was that was really what
happened uh you know i think everyone
was kind of just scared in your car to
like know what was gonna happen um you
know i was afraid i was gonna lose my
job for whatever reason um and yeah and
just you know gotta get pushed to
working at home and started listening to
a bunch of podcasts
and next you know i came um
came upon uh the deafery um a defeat
degree
from anthony o'neil and you know heard
that and i was like wow that changed my
life really um then i started listening
to the obviously dear show
and from then uh just went in overdrive
and you know i had money saved up i
believe i had like maybe like nine or
ten thousand dollars like saved up
and you know i didn't really know what
to do with it and you know obviously
listening to the to the show and the
podcast it just
put everything in perspective and
that's how i really you know kicked off
my journey by knocking out about 9 000
in my first month and from then it just
really kicked off and every month then
um
just
started pounding cash to pay it off as
soon as possible cool you did a great
job man congratulations all right you
did it you're a professional you've uh
you've actually done it it's not a
theory you paid off 46 000 in 16 months
tell people what the key to getting out
of debt is
i think for me
i wrote this down but
the three things i thought
really made helped me get through it all
was one just a budget
once you figure out how much you know is
coming in how much is going out that
really
gives you a better understanding of like
where you can prioritize your money um
so i was the first thing
um then realizing that you know it's
okay to say no to your friends
you know they're always going to be
there
the ones that you know truly love you
will will respect you for it and you
know understand you and what you're
doing so 16 whole months i mean it
wasn't 16 years
yeah yeah exactly and granted i still
had my fun during that time i guess um
and the last thing was just you know
making mini goals um just always having
a goal in mind uh at the end of the
month or quarter or however you want to
you know measure it out but yeah that
was those were my i guess three big
things that kind of helped me
um
and stay motivated through it all
excellent excellent well done very good
good job man how does it feel to be free
oh it feels uh it feels good it feels
weird um i think growing up you know i
didn't really know what that was
and honestly i really didn't like even
when i got to school you know i didn't
see student loans as as a debt i think
nobody really does until
you know
just
um
yeah i don't really know um just
feels weird it feels weird
i think i'm like one of the
first individuals in my family to
become dead at a young age and now just
building upon that and you know making
wealth and
really changing you know myself and you
know my future my future family
it's awesome man i'm proud of you
brother well done sir
we're very proud of you excellent
excellent work absolutely fabulous
fabulous fabulous good good good good we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure and so we want you to go
on now and now that you've gotten rid of
this debt you go ahead and build some
wealth and be outrageously generous in
the process and you are set up to do
that and you got a good career field
you're in you'll be able to do a lot
with that keep killing dragons those
those sorcerers make good money so
keep killing dragons and finding
crystals and stuff yeah
shut up john
[Laughter]
oh my gosh i'm going to crack up and not
be able to get back from this so all
right now here's what we're going to do
you got that we're also going to send
you a copy the total money makeover book
for you to give away and disturb someone
else's life and uh in a good way and so
we're proud of you man all right steph
count it down 46 000 paid off in 16
months making 65 to 90. let's hear a
debt-free scream all right one two three
i'm jeffrey thanks guys appreciate it
that wasn't a scream that wasn't a
scream that was a debt free statement
that was like i did it i'm dead free
yeah
i know but if you're cool and you're hip
in austin
well it may be against city maybe
maybe he's in his office
oh yeah that's true or maybe that's a
sorcerer
he was in his wizarding class and
he couldn't yell out loud you are not
right
oh my goodness gracious
all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money tax season is upon us
i know try to contain your excitement no
one
no one likes doing their taxes
i hate my taxes i hate them especially
when you realize the big software
companies and if you've been doing your
your taxes when those software companies
you find out what they're up to every
year they lure you in saying you can
file for free
but then when you're knee deep in the
filing process they sucker punch you
with up
charges loan offers credit card pitches
and all the other distractions i was
just trying to do my taxes well there's
a better way to do it it's called ramsey
smart tax it's our online tax filing
software with ramsey smart tax you can
get all the deductions all the forms and
every tax break you deserve the best
part is the price
ours is already much lower than the
leading competitor and you won't have
any hidden fees and there won't be any
cross-sells or promotions or anything
else pushing you into doing something
stupid with with your
money in your life don't do that no
so here's the thing we have a promo code
that'll make it free to file your
federal taxes go to ramseysolutions.com
smart tax to get the promo code and file
without the surprises
ramseysolutions.com
smart tax and that will get you there
without a doubt
so good stuff
so here's the thing
it is interesting for those of you
listening
that um some of you have everyone has a
different starting point
because of their
upbringing
their area of the country
their uh
family lineage
their race creed color national origin
drama trauma
everybody's got a different starting
point
and so when i talk to someone like steph
and he says you know the big part of
this is
the breakthrough here is i'm the first
one in my family because my i didn't
even realize student loan debt was
really dead right
that's a that's a starting point
and other people are going well i
already knew all this stuff some of you
are some of you have a really good
starting point where you already
are way ahead and all you need to do now
is get disgusted and do it then go do it
yeah you got to get your butt in gear
get get some action going you know
and others of you
you know we know you can do it because
other people have started way
you know you have what's known like a
race in the backyard when you're a kid a
head start that's right it doesn't mean
you get to win
doesn't mean you're you know but you do
have a head start because you got you
actually know things your family
actually taught you things
you know you knew this was stupid but
you did stupid anyway that's a head
start yeah that's a head start
but just to discover the idea that this
is actually debt that's starting back
their way yeah that's a pretty
interesting thing to make it this far
this fast pretty interesting thing there
so fun fun fun
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day matthew 18 20
for where two or three are gathered in
my name there i am with them helen
keller said alone we can do so little
together we can do
so much lindsay is with us in st louis
hi lindsay welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave thanks for taking the call my
pleasure what's up
great so my husband and i own five
rental properties and four of them have
loans
they all
have a positive cash flow each month and
it's not income that we rely on
currently
but we hope to be financially
independent and then that would be our
sort of income once we stop working what
is the total debt on all of them if you
total them all up
total is right at 105 000 that pays off
all of the properties
yes wow
we bought them pretty well
so the women these are inexpensive
properties then
right they're single family homes that
are worth what each
um they would be worth anywhere from
probably fifty to seventy five thousand
yeah okay
they're a small town yeah cool i like
this yeah it's like it's like numbers
from the 70s or something yeah yeah
okay um you got five houses with a
mortgage jeez okay so what's your
household income
um right now we've at the beginning of
2020 my husband and i both left our jobs
and um became independent contractors um
so we do construction and remodeling so
it varies a little um but somewhere
around probably 75 000.
okay
and what do you owe on your personal
residence
uh nothing
and you're debt-free except for this
hundred and five thousand
correct yeah
okay all right
and your question is how to pay them off
or when to pay them off or should you
keep them or all that right
right so
all i would do is just i would just
treat this like it was a hundred
thousand dollar student loan debt let's
get rid of it crush it yeah i would you
know i think you could pay it off in
like three years without any trouble and
then you have the whole portfolio free
yeah and that's what
we've yeah we've previously just kind of
let the sort of the business take care
of the business and haven't really put
any of what we consider our personal
money towards them so that's what i just
didn't know yeah i think
it is all personal because we're
personally liable on these mortgages
right yeah and so you need to pay them
off yeah let's get them paid off and
because here's what's going to happen
you have so much money then
that you're going to be able to pile up
these rents and buy another property
with cash
yeah and then buy another property with
cash and then buy another property with
cash and that's what i've done then
you're going to run this small town
lindsay
lindsay the landlord this is my town
lindsay my town the landlord
just call me the landlord
yeah i like it i like it this is great
i'm proud of you this is fun thank you
so how far out saying how far out
outside of st louis are you
um i lived about an hour or so north of
saint louis
do you want to reveal the name of the
small town i don't know if you do since
it's a small town uh well the town that
we have the properties in is louisiana
is what
louisiana missouri yeah yeah i know it
well okay
like oh it's over by troy right
yeah it's pretty near to there yeah yeah
that's where my mom's from is over in
there okay wow
interesting wow okay cool
that's a great farming community is what
it is
yeah yep fun
fun fun fun fun all right well let's do
it get it get it you're you're amazing
i've had a lot of calls i haven't had
five mortgages with a hundred grand
total yeah that's a new one yeah
well but yeah and it's been a long time
since i've talked to anybody bought a
house for 75 000 either but i used to
buy them for a lot less than that but
back in the day but cheap houses but
that's a long time ago and
and they were really cheap bad houses
these aren't bad houses these are great
little houses is what these are
not tiny houses little houses there's a
difference okay
sarah's with us in denver hey sarah
welcome to the ramsay show
sarah
hi there dave sorry about that thank you
so much for having me how can we help hi
there john
um yeah so i've just started the
financial peace university which has
been great so far i've
surpassed that baby step one and i'm on
baby step two
and my question um sorry here in a route
but uh my question is
um
this the dead snowball
um i'm having a hard time reconciling
that only because i'm dealing with
a couple of uh factors being that i have
seven credit cards
at zero percent interest
and what's the balance
the total balance is going to be
somewhere around gosh off the top of my
head maybe
15 k and what's your household income
income is about 82 okay and what do you
do for a living
i just started as a software engineer so
i just switched correct
so now i'm actually able to manage
uh my finances my asking will be better
than a great question that a software
engineer would ask so that's perfect
um
so here's the here's what we have
figured out because i would have asked
the same question on financial
background
and it didn't because the debt
snowball's not mathematically correct
when you pay off smallest to largest
regardless of interest rate that's not
mathematically correct mathematically
correct would be to pay off the highest
interest rate first
the avalanche right
well yeah that's what other people
started calling it years after the dead
snowball was famous some character came
up with the avalanche but anyway but the
uh the the concept doesn't work
with the avalanche and the reason it
doesn't work is personal finance is more
behavior
than it is math it's 80 behavior 20
head knowledge
if you try to fix a behavior problem
with math you're going to struggle but
you can fix math with a behavior change
and so the reason i'm telling you all
that is that the human
heart needs to see
traction in your world we'd call it
gamified
so the debt snowball is gamified you're
gamifying yourself when you pay off the
little one regardless of the interest
rate
you're have accomplished a portion a
tiny little portion an incremental goal
that gives you hope that this is
actually going to freaking work then
when you pay off the next one you go a
little bit more excitement when you pay
off the next one you get a little bit
more excitement when you pay off about
four or five of these things or six of
these things and this snowball starts to
roll regardless of the interest rates
you get so stinking excited and
believing and hope-filled
and you you get blinders on and you
start sacrificing deeper and
your progress accelerates and the
probability of getting out of debt and
the speed of which you get out of debt
is even better with a debt snowball even
though it's mathematically incorrect
and there's been several studies
actually done that prove that by the way
yeah i mean i think the biggest thing
for me is that my student debt has been
the absolute bane of my existence yeah
what you're going to get rid of
you make plenty of money it's going away
it's all going away and i kind of want
it hanging out there to just keep that
fire going i want you to stay pissed off
at it but get just get really mad at
this whole thing and go all right i'm
sweeping these mosquitoes under the
sweeping these mosquitoes inside these
stupid little credit cards so i can just
draw back and punch this student loan in
the nose baby i'm gonna smack it
it gets visceral
and when you can kind of get that stuff
going and instead of you getting
instead of trying to mathematically
analyze this that's when you're going to
have more success and that's coming from
a guy who's a math nerd
and your math got you seven credit cards
to begin with
seven
and student loans you were trying to win
the zero percent game and you
lost
so
one of the best predictors of future
behavior is your past not always but
it's a good it's a good baseline
you've tried the math game and it hasn't
worked no so just try something
different trial or try something
different yeah i mean if some if a year
from now you're worse off than you were
then change and ramsay was crazy yeah
there you go you have to get in line on
that one but yes you're right right
you know what i mean like it's it's i
hear people at the beginning of the year
call you know call my show about losing
weight or fixing their marriage and well
this year we're just we're going to go
back to our workout do something
different yeah it's not working change
the recipe different keep getting
chocolate cake i didn't want chocolate
cake change the recipe change it man
change the recipe something different do
something different doing the same thing
over and over again you can do it
do something different definition of
insanity john deloney thanks for hanging
out you're welcome man guys in the booth
great job today i am dave ramsey your
host will be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you